[Musique]
dès le début de sa carrière le pilote
automobile jacques villeneuve négociait
déjà ses virages dans les paradis
fiscaux à compter de 1992 des sociétés
écrans des fiducie ont été mis sur pied
dans les caraïbes pour recueillir des
revenus du champion québécois selon une
nouvelle fuite gigantesque de données
confidentielles
ce serait
les pandores rappeurs ont été obtenus
par le consortium international des
journalistes d' enquête non radio canada
est un partenaire près de 12 millions de
documents internes provenant d'une
multitude de cabinet qui offre des
services d'incorporation de sociétés
dans divers paradis fiscaux plus de 600
journalistes des quatre coins de la
planète ont fouillé ces données pendant
des mois
on y trouve les noms de 35 chefs d'état
anciens et actuels dont l'ex premier
ministre britannique tony blair qui
avait pourtant décrié dans le passé
lusage des paradis fiscaux
il a évité de payer au moins 500 mille
dollars en taxes municipales en faisant
l'acquisition de manoir à londres par
l'entremise d'une société des îles
vierges britanniques
grâce à des sociétés écrans le premier
ministre de la république tchèque a fait
l'achat d'une villa de 28 millions $
dans le sud de la france sans dévoiler
dans ces divulgations public d'actifs il
doit faire face à l'électorat vendredi
lors des élections législatives
on avait des chefs d'état qui eux-mêmes
veut dire profiter du régime
extraterritoriale pour dissimuler des
avoirs personnels n'en commet ensuite
croire le discours public bitumée
la fuite dévoile aussi que de nombreuses
vedettes utilisent les paradis fiscaux
comme le célèbre chanteur elton john qui
perçoit ses revenus à l'étranger depuis
des sociétés aux îles vierges
britanniques
le plus célèbre des chanteurs de charme
de la planète julio iglesias et derrière
une vingtaine de sociétés aux îles
vierges britanniques dont certaines ont
servi à acheter des propriétés de luxe
près de miami
[Musique]
le canadien elvis stojko champion
olympique de patinage artistique
acheminer des actifs d'une valeur de 6
millions 500 mille dollars à une fiducie
au belize il dit qu'ils agissaient sur
les conseils de son avocat et qu'on lui
avait assuré que c'était légal jacques
villeneuve qui vit maintenant en italie
a refusé de répondre à nos questions
concernant les sociétés qu'il a utilisée
dans les caraïbes les avocats qui
représentent le champion de formule 1
affirme qu'il ne souhaite faire aucun
commentaire en raison d'un litige fiscal
qui l'opposait à revenu québec ici
frédéric zajac radio canada vancouver